luno the fastest easiest way to buy crypto
if you're just getting into bitcoin it's the
perfect place to start hey guys and welcome back
to my show hope everybody is doing great today
um this is powered by icon plus so a quick
news announcement for you so in march
icons user-friendly defi project balance will be
released a dow platform that creates icon tokens
pegged to real-world assets like the dollar gold
and oil now i want to say thank you to my sponsors
block fi so i use them to earn up to 8.6 interest
on my usdc you can also get 250 up to that when
you sign up so i'd really recommend them i use
them they're doing incredible stuff now before
i bring on my guests who is a really good friend
of mine um i also want to give a quick shout out
to coinflip so they are doing amazing work across
the states and to push bitcoin mass adoption they
have over a thousand atms and you can actually get
10 off um transactions with them so i will leave a
discount code for you now guys if you are watching
on youtube please don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe so you never miss any of my
fantastic guests so joining me today is a really
brilliant friend of mine somebody that i think is
doing amazing work in the space it is of course
bitcoin liz what's up hey thanks for having me
on once again i really really enjoyed it last
time and uh yeah it's great to be back always
fun to have a chat with you about crypto and
everything that's going on in the world yeah it's
good to chat to you um i feel like we both have um
really similar kind of perspectives on things um
so it's really cool to bounce off each other so
this week has been absolutely mad um we've seen
tesla get in um to crypto 1.5 billion dollars um
you know on their balance sheet so what do you
think about this because before before we jump
into it i just want to say that i've done a lot
of videos about this with on tick tock right
and it's quite unbelievable how much negativity
there still is towards bitcoin yeah like i get
people saying to me all the time it's not true
it's a scam and i'm like it is true yeah they
did put 1.5 billion and what are your thoughts
yeah so first of all comment on that it's it's
always the the ones who have negative thoughts
about it they probably are like regretting not
getting into it earlier so they're just you know
mad and spreading all that but because i mean you
and tiktok you get so many views you're like super
huge people find it interesting so yeah i i it's
always that the negative people you they are the
loudest but actually i think uh yeah people are
changing their mind and specifically looking you
at tick tock it's amazing what you do i think
that's a huge part of uh yeah getting people to
know more about bitcoin but yeah as you mentioned
with with tesla and all that uh really focus has
turned uh towards bitcoin and uh no one can ignore
it anymore and and i have like previously also
uh in my latest video spoken about that i have
like old co-workers that i work with long time
ago reaching out to me and asking about it and
i yeah so so people are really interested these
are the same people that i spoke with them about
bitcoin like two years ago they had no interest in
it so i think even though we still might hear the
negative thoughts about it people are actually
really interested in in bitcoin and yeah a lot
thanks to tesla and elon musk being uh going out
and saying that he supports it if the world's
richest man does it i mean something that that's
really something to keep an eye on uh i believe at
least yeah i think you make a really interesting
point you know you have people who we knew from
years ago calling up and asking us you know how
how can i buy bitcoin so i kind of want to talk a
little bit about that because i often find that um
i have people that i went to school with i have um
my friends and parents messaging me and so on
asking me how they can get in and i often feel
some responsibility and concern about onboarding
new people into the space um i think that
you know even something as simple as sending
bitcoin from one wallet to another i think has its
complications understanding what a wallet address
is it it takes some sitting down and explaining so
my concern is number one i don't have necessarily
the time to sit with somebody and go through the
whole shebang you know um so how do you do it you
don't really want to do it half-hearted because
then if there's a problem they'll come back and
blame you you know if they get their funds stuck
somewhere so what do you do when people ask you
and you obviously don't want to be rude and sort
of say yeah yeah i don't know what do you do so
actually i have got the exact question that you're
proposing now about asking do i need a wallet
how do you actually send transactions and one
one of my previous uh classmates from school
he actually asked about it and he was like oh
i paid this miners fee what is this you know
so yeah i as you said it takes time to explain
and i'm not sure like what level they are at uh
they were asking about okay sushi and in the sushi
swap and all that so i was like thinking that okay
he has probably done a little bit of research but
in the end i i think just what i do is uh redirect
them to good pages that i find uh really for
simple to to read about i think binance has like
their academy that is super super like easy to
so those are really for beginners and just
good articles because it takes too long time to
uh to explain and at some point they
have their own responsibility to do
their own research about it like and understand
so linking to good uh good material is what i do
and then of course try to explain as good as i can
with my own words but yeah it's it's difficult uh
but i i don't feel that we have the responsibility
to do that of course we can just encourage them
and get into and read more about it like this is
really interesting if you understand it it's super
cool but go and read here because i think it's
important that they read with their own words and
and get their own understanding um yeah that's
my thought on it at least how do you do it yeah
i mean it just terrifies me honestly because when
bitcoin when we had that initial bull run earlier
this year i had a lot of people asking me how
to get in and i think that's fantastic and i do
really really want to help but it's it's
a to get somebody in who knows nothing is
really a matter of holding somebody's hand um and
number one you know that that takes time and we've
all got sort of like jobs to do and so on um but
i i'm just i'm not genuinely i'm just a bit afraid
of um something sort of going wrong and it being
my fault because you know i had somebody say to me
um just here's like a general example someone
asked me a question what exchange would you
recommend so i thought okay well gemini's really
cool um you know try out gemini um they're really
cool check out luno whatever and i think they went
for gemini just because they knew the winker boss
twins so they were like cool we'll go for gemini
um and i said great then they asked me what do you
use and i said well i use this platform and they
said well why are you using that and i'm using
this and i was like oh that's how we're going to
have a problem because a lot of the time people
who are already in the space aren't using those
kind of on-ramp and off-ramp um exchanges they're
using things let's say like crypto.com as an
example or blockfi as an example um you know it's
different because that takes i think a level of
um understanding it's not like your first port of
call when you get into crypto so i don't know i'm
still trying to work it out um i'm just you know
and then i think he i think that's the same person
sort of asked me like um it's asking me to do like
a wire transfer what is that and i'm like well
if you don't know what that is i can't help you
i get afraid i don't i just don't want to be held
responsible essentially i agree i agree uh with
because the interesting part is that i think um
now that the friends that or old friends that have
contacted me lately they are not interested in
bitcoin they're asking about other alts that
are discovered and that makes me like a little bit
afraid because they're like okay is there anything
else you can recommend i'm like i have just told
them like take a look at east it's easy to unders
you know like like they're like okay but is there
anything else you can recommend i'm like no no you
have to look on your own what do you like what you
need to like the project you need to understand it
and then you can invest but yeah so that kind
of advice i i don't want to give either because
it's risky especially for those who are not that
involved in crypto and for them it's maybe just
enough that i mentioned one project they're like
okay they said this i'm gonna go in and not even
read about it what what they do or or anything so
yeah it's tricky it's because you don't want to
be rude as well as you said but you don't want to
give them too much advice that they can later come
back to you and say like hey this is your fault so
yeah yeah i think you then you make an interesting
point like everybody's looking for that low-cap
gem um that's that's just gonna go you know
they're looking for that that doge or they're
looking for that i think uma was not over 100
the other day um and i for me personally i i
sort of turn around and say look like for me i
see bitcoin as that long-term store of value um
i think eth is really interesting i do believe
it's undervalued right now so i'd say check
that one out everything else i believe is um
very much to do with how you feel about
that project um and whether you like the
fundamentals of the project or not then
you can do your own research from there um
and everyone's sort of like but bitcoin's too
expensive um i had a friend actually text me
and she said and she said um leia shall i get
doge it's so cheap right now tell me i'll do it
i'm like whoa how do you respond to that if they
should buy dojo for bitcoin you just say like
sorry i i can't advise you on that i don't know
it's tricky but i the the point really that you
made with that everyone thinks that bitcoin is
too expensive i experienced the same thing with
one of my old co-workers and he said like i'm not
he was like completely sure i'm not getting into
bitcoin because it's too late now it's too
expensive so i'm gonna find these the other
ones and this was the same day when elon musk
went out and said that he supports bitcoin on
clubhouse and i was just like think you will go
in bitcoin the same day or the same time as elon
musk you're not too late but yeah yeah there's a
lot of newcomers who uh who think that way right
um and yeah and then they want to go for doge or
something else that you mentioned so yeah it's
crazy newcomers and like retail investors aside
it's been a really interesting week so i've got
a list here so actually i don't have a list here
i have it somewhere else but i do have mastercard
written down so martial is a really interesting
one because they um i believe have confirmed that
um they will start um allowing people to actually
use cryptocurrency on their network so we don't
know which cryptos yet from my research i believe
it's going to be very much stable coin focused
um which is cool i think that's really cool i
think people in the space that will want to be
that will have cryptocurrency to spend or people
that will have cryptocurrency spend will be people
in the space who therefore don't really want to be
spending their bitcoin so having it a stable coin
focus will be really cool but it's down to the
merchants and whether the merchants want to accept
bitcoin so what do you think do you think the
likes of starbucks you know your everyday coffee
shop is gonna be um down with this i mean yeah now
with the mastercard news of course i think there
might be now it seems more likely that it can
happen at some point i thought it was quite far
away but it would be interesting to see what what
the mastercard thing actually will mean and as you
said which cryptocurrencies they will support but
i think it's closer than we think yeah for sure
uh you can do it already now with some crypto
cards that you have that you you have so so why
not uh i think it's it can be doable of course uh
but it yeah it's going to be really interesting to
see exactly what what it means and what they what
they have planned uh with the crypto part actually
because now with they haven't come out and
said really much right they just said that
they're gonna know so so what we know is that it's
definitely not gonna be um like a crypto card like
we currently have so i think mastercard are the
ones that have partnered with um the other crypto
cards like um wirex and up hold so it's not going
to be a matter of just take you know when you like
top up your card it changes to fiat it's not going
to be like that it's going to be actual crypto
um and i think that's insane and i i'm personally
just so excited to see what this means um i think
it adds so much credibility to the space like
i said yeah there's so let's just like take
tesla versus this mastercard news i understand
that they're different but i really think the
mastercard news is actually bigger just because
it means something to the average day person so
yeah okay tesla kind of solidifies bitcoin as
that store of value and it gives it credibility
but what does that mean for your friend that's
not in crypto well it doesn't really mean anything
because some people don't want to buy bitcoin
and have it as their store of value they don't
even think they need a store of value but yeah and
then also and then also in terms of like actually
paying i think this mastercard news gives crypto
an even stronger use case um for those outside of
the space yeah that's a really good point when you
put it that way it totally makes sense because as
well like everyone has some at some point had
probably a mastercard credit card so they they
can relate to that uh with with tesla and elon
musk i know there's a lot of people at least like
like in sweden and who who think he's a little bit
crazy you know a little bit special so they can
be like oh it's just because you know he's like
that but at the same i don't buy i don't buy that
that argument at all but that can be
something but as you said mastercard adds
a lot of credibility and uh yeah problem is maybe
a bigger bigger news um true very true and also
another i'm not sure if it's confirmed
yet but blackrock is it uh at least like
they bought a few weeks ago
yeah i think they did it
okay so now maybe it is confirmed so i think more
and more like investment companies and like that
will probably see it as a like natural way to go
as well and that will even add more credibility
uh to to bitcoin uh so it's yeah i think the fact
that we are dark web intern money it's just forget
about it and now it it there's too many things
pointing the other direction and uh there's
something for everyone that they can relate to
and understand and yes why it is uh yeah good
and somebody's just put in the comments someone
just put in the comments um i'll put it up on
the screen actually somebody wrote um what are the
tax implications if we use crypto to buy a cup of
coffee so that's actually a really cool question
um i honestly don't entirely know um but i think
that's going to be something that will have to
be solved i think the tax issue i think the tax
topic is still really complicated because then
it's different in every in every i'm just gonna
say state i'm not even american it's different
in every state it's different in every country
it's different in every jurisdiction um what
i think um in terms of the way that i do it
i guess if you get paid in bitcoin you
would naturally write down or you know
you you would account for every single payment
that you've received and then if you go buy a
cup of coffee with bitcoin and it costs you
x amount of satoshi's then you would have to
obviously record that um but then again if it's
your party but then again i guess if it's your
personal money then and you've already paid tax
on it then it doesn't matter but then i guess if
there are the capital gains and you're holding
your money in bitcoin it doesn't matter i mean
i couldn't tell you i absolutely don't know
it's still something i'm learning myself
i think because now for example with i have the
pluto's card and if i use it here in sweden i
need to account for every transaction i do with
it so there is more work with it so probably
as it looks like right now it would be the same
in most countries for for this mastercard thing
but assuming how big they are they would probably
think about a better solution that is easy to use
for everyone because otherwise it kind of loses uh
its purpose uh people don't want to have more work
to do or more accounting to do because they want
to use crypto on their on their mastercard and
also it is stable coin based so yeah i'm not sure
how how how the implications will be given if it
you know is pegged to your local currency then it
will be like using your local currency um but also
bny melon um so they're actually the oldest
bank in america i actually i don't know a
couple of people that used to work there so
they are now um able to be bitcoin custodian so
this is interesting because it kind of plays
off against the narrative you know um not your
keys not your coins but then at the same time new
people getting in especially the especially the
kind of clients that bny mellon would have who
come from a more traditional kind of background
might prefer to have um their cryptocurrency in
the custody of somebody else they don't have to
have that responsibility so in terms of let's just
talk about mass adoption because i kind of feel
like this is what it is how do you think that's
going to go do you think that people are going to
feel they don't really want the responsibility of
holding their own keys um do you feel that having
these cus these custodians coming into the space
is actually quite a healthy thing for adoption
good good question i think that if you look at
how how it is today we the majority of people
they trust the banks a lot with all kinds of
information about this so i think naturally
for the bigger mass they will probably don't want
to have access to or be the ones responsible for
their keys um that's just an initial thought but
the whole idea with crypto at least we who are
here now is that we should be the ones responsible
for it and the ones who uh have responsibility for
so i think there will be probably two parts to it
um depending on how deep you are into it uh yeah i
i don't know yeah i haven't actually thought about
that so much uh interesting but what do you think
how it's yeah i can't help but think that those
um people that would be with clients of bny melons
would appreciate having their cryptocurrency
in their custody i can't help but think that um
and that's not just their own clients but i
think it's the majority of people and i think
if we look at the way society votes if we look
at the way society is run i do think people
a a large a large majority of the population
definitely enjoy a lack of responsibility over
certain sorts of things um and i can understand
that when it comes to your finances i think it's
it's really scary you know to think well i am
actually responsible i need to remember the
seed phrase i need to remember my private
keys my public keys i need to um have it
written down or do i not want it written down just
in case you know do i keep it in my head what if
all these different things and and i can totally
understand the the why that's scary i mean if i'm
really honest i often find i don't even like
so i use 2fa obviously and but i don't really
like it um you know i'm just concerned that i'm
going to have an issue with my phone or my laptop
and i know there's ways to recover it they have
like the equivalent of a seed phrase and so on but
it's still it still freaks me out and i think
in terms of mass adoption that is going to be
the kind of um way we're going to see things
go i don't think people will be like you and
i and be like not your keys not your coins yeah
yeah exactly then we can see of course just with
the regular passwords how many people forget
the rest of those normal we do it you know so
yeah probably will go that way that's um and i
think people will be fine with it they probably
just would want to have a part of uh like crypto
as an asset and don't care about having the
the ownership or the responsibility of
the priority yeah i think that's what it
is because if you think about it the everyday
person isn't um investing in the stock market
it's just not happening right um a lot of people
um are talking about a lot of people are waking
up to this kind of idea of inflation and okay well
you should be investing in the stock market then
your average person doesn't do that so i feel like
cryptocurrency um the old coins will sort of i
think fair in an equivalent manner in that people
don't really choose the average person who doesn't
know how to change how to trade won't necessarily
play around in those markets um but in terms
of having um in a pre uh an appreciating asset
then i definitely think people will be choosing
bitcoin and i don't think that they're going to
care whether it's in the custody in the course
i kind of say that word today the custody of
themselves or a custodian um i just i don't
think they're going to care so much um but let's
talk about eth because you are bullish on eth as
always so give me your give me your thoughts
on each price this week it's nearly hitting um
2k yeah i think it will first of all
i need to check the price now where
so definitely i think we should reach 2k very soon
like like this week for sure um and after that i
still think it is sleeping like hell we i i don't
understand why we don't take off yet um but i
think it will definitely happen even though i mean
bitcoin might go down and eastwood might like go
up and i still think that it is uh yeah sleeping
totally because just if you think about all
the everything that's been going on around d5 it
needs to be involved in that and that's that's
where everything is built now i know many are like
really critical towards it because of the gas fees
that they're really high but it's insane honestly
there's yeah it is but at the same time there's so
much going on and there's um so many gains being
made so just everyone needs a fast way to transact
so then yeah they are willing to pay more so
these if you have a transaction that is worth like
millions of dollars then a fifty dollar eat fee
gas fees is um is not that like significant it's
because they need to have it fast and that's
when they're when they're willing to pay more
and when it comes to everyday transactions
smaller transactions i saw you posted about
finance and their pancake swap um as well that
can be like a replacement for eth when it comes to
all these smaller transaction everyday
transactions that are super cheap
because basically what they've done they have
copied it but it's just much cheaper so i think
that part can solve the the one the part that
everyone is so critical about when it comes
to it why it's so expensive because for the big
transactions it's not expensive people are willing
to pay that for everyday smaller transactions yes
i understand that people are um yeah a little bit
angry about the gas we but then we have yeah
pancake swap for that instead for example
yeah i think you make a good point those gas fees
are pretty insane um i actually tried to send well
i didn't try i did i sent um about 70 um and i in
usdc maybe i don't remember um and i think i paid
22 in gas fees which is totally unacceptable and
it's literally theft um so my kind of analysis
and perception on all of this is i definitely see
value beneath i think it's undervalued um as it is
um you know like i said there's there's like you
said sorry there's a huge there's a huge um need
and narrative for decentralization particularly
when it comes to um apps yesterday um youtube
took down one of my videos for absolutely no
reason yeah yeah we can talk about that and
remind you okay um yeah we can talk about that
so later down on my video so there's a need and
an argument for it i just wonder whether
there will be other um networks that other
chains whatever blockchains that will just do
it better um i wonder whether it's kind of like
ethereum is this let's just call household name
i realize it's not a household name yeah but you
know they've they've gotten to a place where you
know it's ethereum and they've built a name for
themselves and and it's it's the go-to it's the
go-to um protocol everything's being built on top
of it but i just wonder if something else i don't
know like tomo chain or something like that could
come along finance chain um all these different
things could potentially come along and take over
i don't i don't know i just think those gas fees
are left in my opinion yeah yeah when you put it
that way of course they they seem like that but i
think in the long term it won't matter because uh
people will still continue to transact with it the
ones that the big transactions um i think will be
done there and and and still i think the important
part with ethereum is the community it won't go
anywhere people are so like hardcore building and
i think that matters a lot of course there might
come other solutions but they're probably not
going to take over it so to say probably there
there can be better um solutions of course but
i think it's it's like with bitcoin you know
everyone knows about it it's impossible to you
know it's it's impossible to to take over and i
think we're a little bit in in the same situation
with it and but i said people can use other
possibilities for those smaller transactions so
they avoid the the high gas fees um so it's just
you have other options you don't need to to choose
or use it for for those smaller transactions uh so
i think it won't disappear anyway but i completely
hear how frustrating it must be if you send like
yeah sixty dollars and you pay twenty dollars for
emp that's that's insane that's insane yeah yeah
it is pretty mad and i'm just hoping um and i'm
sure it will come um something will solve that i
mean we're waiting on 82.0 kind of still so we'll
see how that goes um but in terms of mass adoption
then right so bitcoin has that narrative for it
being a store of value i think at this point it's
easier to sell to your friends and your
family pick bitcoin it's you know tesla
picked it so you know it's obviously it can
it's obviously uh credible but how does one
sell eth right like it doesn't hold that
store of value narrative it just doesn't
um somebody that i used to work with um always
said something which has always stuck with me he
said that bitcoin is digital gold and then eth is
digital well i say digital that doesn't work it's
like digital amazon um amazon but and it is a form
of and it is like amazon i think those are the two
that's the two best comparisons that i can
give so it's really hard to sort of sell
sell that to somebody um because why why does
my friend down the road um care about defy um
why does she care about deep i can understand why
those in more developing countries that don't have
the kind of financial infrastructure that we have
um would definitely appreciate being able to um
you know lend borrow and all these things that
and decentralized finance can offer but i don't
i don't know how you're supposed to sell that
narrative to the average person other than
the decentralization narrative and the need for
daps and stuff like that other than that i can't
work out how to sell that how would you do it yeah
so i think to understand it properly as you said
probably the average joe on the street won't
won't get it in the same way you kind of need
to have an interest for maybe finance and know how
things work in order to to be able to understand
what possibilities there are with eth so
definitely it's not that easy to sell in
as uh as bitcoin i agree with that but if people
have interest for for finance and and how all that
works i think it's like they will understand it
right away um because basically what is it's it's
programmable money it's it's super cool if you
think about it it's it's interesting so i'm just
going to jump in though because when j when uh jk
rowling got as if that just slipped out of my head
when jk rowling um was like what's bitcoin can
someone explain it to me people use that term
it's programmable money and she's like what on
earth does that mean but literally like what does
that mean you know like how do you break down the
term programmable money yeah that that's that's
one topic in itself but if you think about it it's
just what everything is it's just a line of like
code basically in on the blockchain it's it's
not more more than that and yeah i i don't know
i always settle i always settle for the for the
amazon argument the way like um you can do all
sorts of thing on amazon you know you can watch
movies you can buy books you can um get a kindle
you can buy all sorts of different things i think
does amazon have music now do they have like a
spotify equivalent i think they do probably yeah
i'm not sure yeah i think they do i'm not sure
but that's the best way that i explain it when
i say programmable money i'm just sort of like
you can program it to do many different things
um that's the only way i can put that forward
but i know that narrative didn't stick
with uh jk rowling very well yeah
so what i would ask like instead like what what
is fiat money then if you think it's just a bunch
of numbers on on a like spreadsheet that's all
it is it doesn't have anything behind it nothing
it's just people type in numbers on a spreadsheet
that's all what it is so at least with bitcoin or
ethereum well bitcoin specifically its
program we know there will only be 21
million this there are specific ways to acquire
it there are specific ways to transact it and
yeah i mean it's so much more secure no one
can tamper with it and and all that so i i
guess maybe that's a way to explain that program
money it's it's a secure no one can tackle with it
but regular money it's just a bunch of numbers
without yeah what you can manipulate as easily as
you want i don't know maybe that's that's the way
to put it yeah no i get that and i think i think
this uh i say this year i think last
year and this year is definitely
one of the most amazing kind of use cases or sorry
case studies even um to show somebody in terms
of manipulating the price of money printing
more money and all these sorts of things um
and i think that idea of you know having that
hedge against inflation because even when you
look at something like gold there's always more
gold to be mined and i think that the value and
the scarcity obviously comes from the fact that
it's it's scarce and it's difficult right like you
literally need to you can go you know you have to
go into the sea you have to go into the ground um
there's and there is enough i read enough um gold
up in the sky or down but in space where everyone
put it up down everywhere um on an asteroid to
make everybody on earth a billionaire but the
interesting part of that fact is that if we if
we then had access to all that gold the value
of it would would just drop anyway so there's
really not enough to make everybody a billionaire
but anyway i'm going on one but that's kind of
the argument that i that i always put forward and
that's kind of why i never understand people
like peter schiff for example who who just
can't who just can't get on it um i don't get it i
don't know whether it's i don't know whether it's
um a generational thing um i'd like to think
not something um that i saw somebody say the
other day i can't remember who it was um i have
no idea who it was maybe somebody in the comments
will tell me when i say but they said something
like the next generation or even our generation
right we find more value in things like spotify
um than vinyl records and cds and things like that
um so looking at bitcoin and gold i think it's
kind of going to be like that i think it's a
generational thing where if you're trying to
explain bitcoin as a digital store of value
to the next generation then i think they're going
to be able to understand bitcoin better than gold
and particularly just given how easy
it is to store it's portable and so on
yeah i agree and i don't i don't think
that gold is like a bad investment it is
good but it's nearly not as good as bitcoin
in my case but with peter schiff specifically
he's like completely rejects rejecting uh bitcoin
which is yeah that's like the the weird part about
him but there's nothing wrong about like having
gold as a store value because yeah it's it's a
good store value it's all right nothing nothing
wrong with that but uh yeah his case is a little
bit funny and the funniest part is that his son
is like super intimate and so i mean it's probably
a generational thing with him at least i i do
think like that because i do see other like older
relatives that i have they they have really
difficult time to understand bitcoin the goal
with gold it's like yeah you understand it so
at some point i do think that it is generational
but at the same time every can everyone can do and
read and learn more about it until we understand
but it's just a little bit more difficult and
i think it's natural um that it is that way
i mean john's really funny about it it's
not just it's not just the likes of peter
schiff who reject it but it's also
um people that just don't understand
the value in it and why we think it's so amazing
so like i'm going to take my dad as an example um
when tesla bought 1.5 billion i turned around
to my dad and was just like can you believe it
like they put this much money in um and he was
like oh okay so when are you selling and i'm
like this is the time to hold because this is when
you hold this is when people foam i win i'm like
what do you mean when am i selling and he's just
like oh you know things go up and down and you
don't want i'm like this isn't the stock market
this is different this is it's that narrative and
it's not i just don't think it's really hitting
home to some people um i don't know have you what
experiences have you had with your family have you
also found that it's not quite hitting home yeah
i i guess so my dad gets quite well i think but
he's not at that point that he would invest in it
because he doesn't understand it that much uh so
i would say i'm i'm a little bit the the outsider
in my family who who wants uh all in or in crypto
but of course they are like very supportive and
yeah they didn't try they understand the basics
i would say but i yeah they probably wouldn't
be able to explain the difference between
bitcoin and eth to some of their friends
or like that um but when it comes to yeah um yeah
i lost my thread okay i thought that's all right
les i want to go back i want to go back to tesla
to be honest because i want to just talk about
what you think that means for the space so
who do you think is going to get in next so
i've been reading a lot into this i know that
apple are rumored to get in next um that's
according to um i think it was the royal bank of
canada um so they're rumored to get in next um
twitter's cfo said on cnbc today that they aren't
necessarily looking i'm sorry not twitter um
uber sorry uber said on um cnbc today that they
aren't necessarily looking to put bitcoin on their
balance sheet but they are considering um people
accepting um payments for uh in crypto for rides
so what are your thoughts on that yeah i think
it's well first of all because tesla is the role
model probably for many companies and um so many
cfos probably are scanning around what are other
companies doing and they see of course also micro
strategy like how much gains they have made after
they put bitcoin on their balance sheet so of
course now they need to look in it it's their
responsibility to look into it if we see that
there are companies that are doing this that are
successful of course they need to do it i mean if
they don't do it they're not good cfos i would say
uh so and i think of course as well it's easier
for for companies like uber who are i mean they
are digital so they kind of understand probably
the product better as well so more companies like
that will i'm sure look into it um and twitter of
course we know that twitter's previous yeah ceo um
is a bitcoin so that's that was quite a amendment
um but probably more like big unicorn startups
uh will will look into it i'm sure because they
also have the pressure now from from shareholders
and and others uh to for for them to perform
well so they need to take the responsibility
and and look into it and that that's yeah
definitely who it is i think a key word there
is responsibility actually it's a really good
word to use because these people these companies
do have a responsibility for their shareholders
to be putting their money in the correct place and
bitcoin is now something which people sort of
agree can't be ignored you know if the richest man
in the world um is he the richest man in the world
i'm not sure i think like he's fluctuating like
bitcoin's price um but i i don't know he he is he
is for a minute and then he's not and then he is
and then it is up and down but yeah if they're
putting on their balance sheet then i do i can
imagine the when that was announced you probably
have like cfos running around like opposites just
like oh my god what do we do like should we be
copying this should we be doing the same thing
um i i think it's insane but another really
interesting topic um that i want to get your
thoughts on is regulation um it's a really cool
topic i like um because there's um kind of this
push and pull in the community between regulation
being necessary to take bitcoin to the next level
um and then and then but also what about freedom
and um you know people's anonymity and like forget
kyc and all this stuff so when um well i spoke
to raul powell and he is a no okay i don't say
he's a fan of regulation he's not read the
point he's more talking about the importance
of it to take bitcoin to that next stage he sort
of says if you want bitcoin to become that that's
that that asset that store value that currency or
whatever you want to call it that major players
are using more regulations could be necessary
so there hasn't been a change in regulation
yet bigger players are getting in so where do
you stand on regulation and it's necessity uh
to take bitcoin to the next step um so in general
of course regulation means it's not always good
but i think it's it's also necessary as as you
mentioned before that it will be a natural part
because now bitcoin is being getting big billions
of uh like in corporations corporations are
investing billions so it it will come i mean if
you want it or not it will come and at some point
it will do good as well because then um other
companies will see that okay now it's actually
regulated now it's secure to invest in it probably
they will think more that way and um so yeah
i think there's both good and bad to it we who
have been in this space for a long time and we've
been here and enjoying all the freedom that we
have we're probably not super big fans of it
but i think there were of course
parts um that they really see that
this is what we need in order to get into it
so yeah i think they're both good and bad but
for bitcoin to become like really global
and really uh like a normal part of a
company's portfolio or a balance cheat
i think it needs to be regulated yeah um
so um yeah there's two yeah first it i can't
really take one or the other side i i don't know
because i think of course yeah go for
it sorry yeah no i think it depends
i think it depends on what we want bitcoin to be
um well that was kind of always my opinion until
more people started getting in until this week
really until tesla and bny melon um bmy melon are
one of the most reputable oldest banks in america
so i find that fascinating um i really do um
because it's because you see there's a difference
isn't there between tesla and and y melon tesla's
tesla's this like new digital kind of like company
that does things in a futuristic manner so it
makes sense um it makes sense you know given who
elon musk is and the things he's interested in
and all that but yeah to have such a traditional
bank take such a leap yeah so it is really cool
um yeah i agree it's super cool but then as well
i don't know if you saw uh i think it was earlier
this morning christine lagarde went out and
said that yeah that central banks having okay
now now this we're not talking about a central
bank but still it's a little bit in in the same
um area that's yeah it's out of the question that
they hold are going to be holding bitcoin and
that's actually like really i don't know how how
we will come across that or by that um but those
are central banks so that that's not the same
thing but um still we do have some challenges to
to get through there are a couple of questions i
want to i want to just uh answer so if anyone has
any questions feel free to throw them now um i'll
answer both of it i'll give this to both of us um
so somebody says do you think bitcoin will stay
above 40k from now on or do you think it will
drop back to lower levels um do you want to go
for that would you want me to go for it first i
can go first so i think staying around 40k is that
we will do that for for some time um so now we are
around yeah 47.3 i think we might drop a little
bit lower uh to but but definitely about 40 for
for some time but then yeah we we might hit bear
market again very soon depends on uh how this um
alt c is going um but yeah it's difficult to say
it's difficult to say at some point as i mentioned
that i have people who were absolutely not
interested in bitcoin before reaching out to me
it's it's kind of also a little bit of a bearish
signal for me because now it's like everyone is
in is this you know sometimes i'm thinking tesla
got in we have more and more companies joining
is this the top now i mean we don't know it might
be it might be at least yeah that's that's what i
think so sometimes uh i don't want to spread any
fun but i think you would like that what are you
no i i i don't think so i don't think so i think
i think things are just heating up honestly um can
bitcoin drop below 40k yeah of course you can drop
like 40k um but will it drop below 30 i am less
sure about that given how we saw what was it
like in the 30s for was it a month or three
weeks or something like that i felt forever
um but but but i think you know that there's
a lot of support between 30 and 40k um which
makes me feel um really optimistic about those
price levels um regarding 40 plus it's impossible
to say it's absolutely impossible to say i think
the only in my opinion the only reason why we
are nearly at 50k right now is because of tesla's
um tesla's investment so we will have to see
whether that holds we obviously saw as a bit of a
dip yesterday we'll have to see how that holds um
but in my opinion um this is not financial advice
but i think i think 30k could potentially be the
bottom and we're kind of here on out from there
um here's another interesting question actually
wait i'm going to ask another one first someone
says what are your thoughts on nfts i know you're
a fan of nfts liz yeah um well i think it's super
cool because we we do see a lot of activity from
uh influential people when it comes to nfts um
soulja boy's got one hasn't he yeah
i think so too yeah yeah i'm not
i haven't uh looked into that but yeah i saw him
tweet tweeting something about i think but we had
more cuban he he were doing he was doing um like
short videos uh yeah kind of nfc thing i think
uh who else do we have um what is it paul logan
is it paul logan what's his name logan paul
like he was an nft and i'm not sure if he but he
was into that he was actually like talking a lot
about uh that and who else we had someone else
as well like hollywood uh hollywood star don't
tell me lindsay lohan's got an nft i think she
has i think i think she did yesterday i'm honest
yeah probably yeah definitely i think she has
an nft actually me and ivan were discussing this
uh yesterday let's see let's i think she actually
hasn't so i think this this is amazing that uh
like influential people are seeing the
use case of it i think it's super cool
and especially because this is something everyone
wants to you know collect something either what
is and this makes also like a physical product
like i have paintings or something it makes it
more special you know because you kind of have
a a specific thing that is is connected to that
what what you can follow so i think it's super
cool and i think this is also something that
people will understand uh because you know we
have pokemon cards what are all the things that
people are collecting so this is just to have
it in a digital way so i i think it's actually
super cool and i think it will probably only
grow especially seeing now all the activity and
people are getting yeah celebrities are involved
in it so uh yeah i'm i'm a big fan of it and i
think uh it will definitely be a part of
like everyday collectibles uh in globally
i think nfts so i'm really i'm really kind of like
drawn um with nfts i'm kind of like torn sorry in
two different places so firstly i totally
understand the need to um put things on the
blockchain um to for authenticity purposes so i
totally get you know putting like um products that
say like designer handbags ornaments paintings and
things like that you know giving them tokenizing
them giving them um a place on the blockchain
and then you can then you know for sure okay well
number one you know it's history which is really
important um when it comes to different things
like i know because my brother's a big fan of
watches i know that um no two no two watches have
the same value where it was made where it comes
from and all this stuff affects the price of it
so i can really understand the um the importance
of that the only thing which gets me is um
it's like this is the selfies if i'm really honest
i don't get it i get that it's fun to give it a go
i'm so i'm so for it i just i'm i struggle and i
spoke to um coin artist marguerite about it and
i just i i can't get my head around it
just because it could just because the
the picture already exists online so i always
struggle to wrap my head around the value of it
um i don't i don't know i struggle yeah i agree
with you i agree with you but when it comes to
i have to tell you like i have to confess i did
sell an nft selfie that was my first one and that
was right why not you know it was just like i need
to try it and it actually goes it's super good but
now when i think about it after it's like don't
don't buy a selfie i mean don't don't i don't see
the value in it either i i really don't uh so yeah
i i think that will probably die out soon that use
case i think it already has pretty much but yeah
that part i i don't understand either well if you
can have like because now what they do is all
kind of digital art and all that which can be
nice as well but you can just still you know you
can copy um or print screen it and just you know
use it anyway but i think when it comes to to give
value when it comes to like you can have digital
collectible cards or something that actually
has some purpose in a game or something and then
it's it's more usable and and i can see a use
case for it but i agree with just a selfie and nah
it's hard it's hard like and i think i think
like they say about beauty i don't know if
this is a british term but i always compare the
two beauties in the eye beholder and i sort of
feel the si i feel the same um sentiment when it
comes to nfts i really think the um the values
in the eye of the beholder like there's value in
anything whereby someone perceives value in it so
whoever bought your selfie finds value in it and
that's super cool um so maybe make another one
um definitely you know if people find value in
it then you know offer offer a service whether
there's value i just find it i just struggle
to kind of figure put my head up get my head
around it like i really get it when it comes
to products um and even even documents for
for houses and things like that and and even
even like domains somebody wrote in the comments
um about unstoppable domains um i get that as
well i really get it um i just struggle when
um when it seems like selfies just because
they've already been posted i don't know
maybe it's just me um but somebody else put in the
comments um a really cool topic um about earning
interest um so i will try to find the question
because i can't remember where it is but someone
asked about how can you earn interest um on
your cryptocurrency so i'll kick that one off
um okay um can you speak about earning interest on
cryptocurrencies okay it's pretty straightforward
so i'll kick that off i mean i earn up to 8.6
interest right now um on my usdc in block five um
i use block fi they do sponsor the show i'm really
open about that um but i actually use them so i
definitely put my money where my mouth is um and i
i think they're really great they pay you monthly
um you can get up to 250 when you sign up um
you can get you can put bitcoin in there you
can put litecoin in there i believe i think they
just it's either litecoin or ethereum they just
increased the amount of interest you can you can
make on there so i i'd recommend them um if you
want to earn interest uh the bank of england i
believe so we can get we can get this interesting
one so the bank of england i think i've just
gone down to zero interest i can't remember i
think it was at 0.01 now it's completely gone
just because of korean virus and all that but
you're dealing with negative interest rates over
there aren't yeah yes i think for the last what
is it five years something yeah it's it's horrible
but it's everyday life here now so yeah that was
what i wanted to to like answer right away like
earning interest yeah that's that's nothing that
we do regular people do in sweden but of course
there are other ways to it and i have to say that
i'm not that um like um i don't know about that
many um like opportunities to earn interest when
it comes to group except blockify blockfi actually
because i did research them one time and i have
had a meeting with someone from their team who
explained it really well and and yeah so i think
that's definitely one of the the best ways to
take a look at if you want to to earn it uh and
yeah the problem which do you use what do you use
so block file you use yeah yeah so that's the like
basically the only one i i know but but there are
more nexo i think or what what are the more um so
you can use crypto.com as well um yeah but there's
there's quite a lot but the fees are different
um and you have to so with crypto.com you can
choose to um get more in to get more interest
so you can get a high percentage if you lock in
for three months so it really it really depends
um so there's another question here um about
link which i think is um oh yeah celsius by the
way guys there's a good one someone's just dropped
that below celsius is also a really good one alex
missions he's cool so oh that's true that's true
um that's a good one um okay wait somebody asked
about link so i can chat about link i don't know
do you want to give your thought thoughts first or
join me to go through it you can go ahead i don't
yes so i think i think link's really interesting
i hold link i'm always really open about what i
do and don't hold um i don't know whether i think
it's interesting that's kind of like the extent to
that i will say um i think if d5 really takes off
i think right now d5 is still very experimental um
but if it does take off then i think um there is a
need for um projects like link um you know i think
there is a i think there's a need for it sorry
so link have that first mover advantage um so
i know there are obviously competitors like
band protocol and so on but link do have that
first mover advantage so if d5 takes off then
link is going to be that what already is that
go-to um but i don't know because it's still
really experimental um is that ivan behind yeah
that was live online yeah hey ivan hello yeah
that's cool um so yeah those those those are my
thoughts on link i don't know if you if you're
watching any other alts other than you i i do
watch and but i don't hold any uh link i have to
say that right away i have thought about it but
i feel like i'm a little bit late to the party
probably not but it just feels like a little
bit too late but i totally understand the like
oracle networks and all that it's a good purpose
and all that so i think we'll definitely perform
good probably and so um yeah um but i don't hold
it okay what are you holding someone's asking
what's in your bag ladies so yeah mostly bitcoin
and eat but i also do have um other smaller old
say i have poo i do have what else what else uh
now since recently i have also execute or create
damn so you're you're really bitcoin underneath
then if you can't think of your head you're
really big for the knee yeah yeah i think i
don't have anything else yeah but i'm really
really big underneath yeah um definitely because
i think like long term and that's that's nice
to hold i think with all uh yeah you can make
really good games uh you you can um but um you
really need to also like all the time follow
and it's a little bit stressful um but yes
yeah if you find like projects you like of course
uh probably now thinking that i should have um
got into polka dot before i don't know it's
like it's too late but i know i remember like
yeah but yeah i know i know but i i kind of
feel like i don't know if if we really have
like topped now because we do do you see a
lot of balls performing like crazy well so
i'm gonna we're in the hospital market as
well so yeah yeah yeah so i'm a little bit
cautious but i remember i was looking into dots
in september and yeah i should have got it but no
it's all right it's right i love
my bitcoin and eat so it's all good
that's good that's good i think uh when people
ask who i own so bitcoin and eth obviously
um and then i do own a few alts um but i
don't watch them at all so i own ada right
and um somebody that i follow tweeted that
ada was up and i was like oh my god like i
haven't even looked at that yeah i don't
i don't watch them i just have them um
because i don't because because i don't know i
was just like playing around so i bought a few so
i bought link i bought ada um i hold ics um
because i am a fan of the project um i do
quite a bit of work with them everyone knows
i'm quite open about that um and oh this is a
strange one that i own again this isn't financial
advice but i own one which is um harmony's um
native token just because just because um
back in july last year i was supposed to do um
an interview with them so i was like i'll buy some
um so i bought some and nothing's really happened
um i wonder if i'm missing any i own blue as well
obviously i own crow because i use crypto.com
oh i don't i should own vt but i don't um
that's always that's always a really good one um
so there you go all right we're coming up to
an hour we've been chatting for uh for a while
wow time flies me neither really someone asked
me why why did my youtube video get removed
yes yes i want to hear that because
yeah this is always frustrating
why well i'm not entirely sure why it got
removed it was literally a um it was literally a
60 second tick tock video um just saying that
guys elon musk's company tesla put 1.5 billion
in um this will make this will solidify bitcoin
as a store of value um blah blah blah credibility
la la la yeah um and it was doing well like it
was doing well i saw that video yeah there you
go yeah yeah i was thinking like oh good you're
posting your tic-tac videos on youtube and yeah
yeah okay so that one got removed what the heck
yeah well and they they didn't really say they
were like it's misleading and i'm like everything
is really factual here i was like everything got
on and they still haven't gone back to me um it's
a bit upsetting to be honest because you know you
we i know people talk about oh you should move to
here you should move to there and we should but
it it's just hard when there's a big audience
obviously um and i know somebody has to take the
first step and i appreciate that but i think it
yeah it's it's difficult to move off of youtube so
um what are you still waiting to hear back
yeah i i guess so and this is your first video
getting removed right now yeah yeah so it's
probably you know sometimes they they just haven't
like they do it automatically without thinking
and i agree moving to another platform it's
easier said than done you kind of still have
your audience there so it will really require
like um a lot of uh struggles because usually you
get straight going a bit oh yeah but you you you
it wasn't they didn't even say but they they
didn't say they said we're not giving you a strike
we we just i think they thought it was like spam
or something um and i'm like what there's so much
spam on there how are you how are you doing we
spam when there's so much ram on that i don't know
they should like seriously work with their ads
because i see this uh like metallic scam ad all
the time when i watch i don't have any youtube
premium so i see that and all the time they should
work more on that because that's really bad like
the scammers right now really bad i don't know
if you saw but i had like there's a lot of people
impersonating me and i had two guys reaching out
to me yesterday and they will literally like
send a thousand bucks to like a bitcoin liz
yeah they did like two confirmed cases there
might be more because it's kind of embarrassing to
admit that that you did it because yeah i mean
yeah it's insane so and they were like complete
newcomers to the space uh and i feel really
really bad for them but this is unfortunately
this is reality in crypto you need to be cautious
uh if something seems too good to be true it is a
scam probably so yeah they they lost their funds
like fortunately it's it's not that much money
but still it's significant to to some people so
yeah yeah just on that point though so here's
something that i experienced and i want to let
you know and i'll see the audience as well because
i experienced a weird one so there was a scammer
um and then somebody with a really really weird
account who had literally just joined um so this
happened in january or december i can't remember
um but somebody who let's say it was
january somebody who had just joined
um that january january 2021 dm'd me and was
like there's a scammer of you um how dare you
not tell the community that there's a scam review
you owe people money now people have lost money
because of you and i'm like are you the scammer
i was like are you trying to get me you know so
it was really really odd like he he took like a
real personal kind of interest in what was going
on um and he'd literally just joined he'd just
joined twitter um as soon as this whole thing had
kicked off so i was kind of just like i need to
block this person you're quite threatening yeah um
because i mean there's so and i don't know if
people know but like so liz you have hundreds
of fake accounts it's unbelievable
they have like 12 000 13 000 followers
i know it's insane i have seen like two of them
one has twelve thousand one thirteen and it takes
time i know they have been around for weeks and
i've asked like everyone i know around me to to
report it but still they have been up i think
now one of them at least is gone but it's insane
it's and it's impossible to stay up
at all it's impossible keep posting so
i think and what i've noticed a lot of people
do they just leave it now um and just sort of
hope that everybody just gets the gist when you're
right when you're in crypto this sort of happens
um so yeah i don't know i thought it was really
strange this guy just pressuring me to announce
this and that otherwise i owe people money
i was like wow this is uh yeah probably was
probably was a scammer he wanted you to say or he
or she wanted you to say something specific that
he or she can use against you or something but
yeah they're getting smarter and more clever
literally they are getting smarter so guys please
be mindful um liz and i will never ask you for
money nobody will ask you for money nobody will
ask you for any private details nobody will ask
you um for any sensitive information where you
live and so on so and if it like liz said if it
does sound too good to be true it probably is and
also here's a funny one if they start the message
off with how's your trade going yeah big red
flag yeah big real conversation like that anyway
where can people find you what are your final
words yeah so everyone can find me on twitter um
liz bitcoin and youtube i've started to upload a
little bit more like short videos when i feel for
it uh it's also a bitcoin list there and instagram
as well but mostly twitter and youtube now yeah
it has been great hanging out with you it was
fun yeah it's been great having you thanks so
much for joining me um it's been super chill um
thank you everyone for watching and thank you
so much for your comments and your questions
it's been really nice just to keep it casual
have it keep it nice and informal so you go guys
thanks so much for tuning in liz thanks for coming
and thank you to my sponsors i will
see you all next week on thursday peace